the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so remember we left things with the
statement of the divergence theorem so
the divergence theorem gives us a way to
compute the flux of a vector field for a
closed surface okay it says if I have a
closed surface s bounding some region D
and I have a vector field defined in
space so then I can try to compute the
flux of my vector field for my surface
double integral of F dot DS f dot NDS if
you want and to set this up of course I
need to use well the geometry of the
surface depending on what the surface is
we've seen various formulas for how to
set up the double integral but we've
also seen that if it's a closed surface
and if the vector field is defined
everywhere inside then we can actually
reduce that to a calculation of the
triple integral of the divergence of F
inside okay so concretely if I use
coordinates let's say that the
coordinates of my vector field are so
the components are P Q and R that NDS
then that will become the triple
integral of well so divergence is P sub
X plus Q sub y plus R sub Z so by the
way how to remember this formula for
divergence and other formulas for other
things as well so let me just tell you
quickly about the Dell notation
so this guy usually pronounced as Dell
have often as you know pointy triangle
going downwards or something like that
it's a symbolic notation for an operator
so you're probably going to complain
about you know my putting these guys
into a vector but let's think of partial
respect to X with respect to Y and
respect to Z as the components of some
formal vector of course it's not a real
vector these are not like you know
anything these are just symbols but so
see for example the gradient of a
function well if you multiply this
vector by a scalar which is a function
then you'll get partial partial X of F
partial partial Y of F partial partial Z
F well that's the gradient that seems to
work and so now the interesting thing
about divergence is I can think of
divergence as del dot a vector field see
if I do the dot product between this guy
and my vector field click you are well
it looks like I will indeed get partial
partial X of P plus partial cube of y
plus partial R partial Z that's the
divergence
okay and of course similarly when we had
two variables only x and y we could have
thought of the same notation just with a
two component vector but for partial X
partial partial Y so now this is like
you know slightly limited usefulness so
far it's going to become very handy
pretty soon because we're going to see
curl and the formula for curl in the
plane was kind of complicated but if you
thought about it in terms of this it was
actually the determinant of del and F
and now in space which we're going to
the del cross F but I'm getting ahead of
things so let's not do anything with
that the curl will be for next week
just getting you used to the notation
especially since you might be using it
in physics already so might be worth
doing okay so the other thing I wanted
to say is what does this theorem say
physically how should I think of this
statement so I think I said that very
quickly at the end of last time but not
very carefully so what's the physical
interpretation of the divergence theorem
so I want to claim that the divergence
of the vector field corresponds to what
I'm going to call the source weight
which is somehow the amount of flux
generated per unit volume so to
understand what that means let's think
of what's called an incompressible fluid
okay so an incompressible fluid is
something like water for example where a
fixed mass of it always occupies the
same amount of volume okay so gases are
compressible liquids are incompressible
basically so if you have an
incompressible fluid flow well so again
what that means is really given mass
occupies always a fixed volume
then well let's say that we have such a
flow with velocity given by our vector a
vector field F okay so we are thinking
of F as the velocity in maybe some
something containing water a pipe or
something so what does the divergence
theorem say it says that you know if I
take a region in space D so it is the
inside and s is the surface around it
well so if I sum the divergence in D
then I'm going to get the flux going out
for this surface s I should have
mentioned it earlier the convention in
the divergence theorem is that we orient
the surface with a normal vector
pointing always Outworld okay so now we
know what flux means remember we've been
describing flux means how much fluid is
passing for this surface so that's the
amount of fluid that's leaving the
region D per unit time and of course
when I'm saying that you know means I'm
counting everything that's going out of
the - everything that's coming into D
that's what the flux measures so now you
know if there's stuff coming into the or
going out of D well it must come from
somewhere you know so one possibility
would be that your fluid is actually
being compressed or expanded but I've
said no I'm looking at something like
water that you cannot squish into
smaller volume so that case your own
explanation is that there's something in
here that actually is sucking up water
or producing more water and so
integrating the divergence gives you the
total amount of sources
amount of syncs that are inside this
region so the divergence itself measures
basically the amount of sources of
things per unit volume at a given you
know in a given place and now if you
think about it that way well so
basically the divergence theorem is just
stating something completely obvious
about you know all the matter that is
leaving that region must come from
somewhere so that's basically how we
think about it now of course if you're
doing 802 then you might actually have
seen the divergence theorem already
being used for things that are more like
force fields say electric fields and so
on well I'll try to say a few things
about that join the last week of classes
but then this kind of interpretation
doesn't quite work ok any questions
generally speaking before we move on to
the proof and other applications yes
oh not the gradient so either the
divergence
yeah the divergence of F measures the
amount of sources of things in there
well what makes it happen if you want in
a way to this theorem or in another way
if you think about it you know try to
look at your favorite vector fields and
compute their divergence and if you take
you know a vector field where maybe
everything is rotating you know flow
that's just auditing about some axis
then you'll find that it's divergence is
zero if you saw no divergence is not
equal to the gradient so it does a dot
here that maybe it's not very big but
it's very important okay so you take the
divergence of a vector field when you
take the gradient of a function so the
gradient of a function is a vector the
divergence of a vector field is a
function so somehow these guys you know
go back and forth between so I should
have said you know with new notations
comes new responsibilities I mean you
know now that we have this nice nifty
notation that will let us do gradient
divergence and later curl in a unified
way if you choose to use this notation
you have to be really really careful
what you put after it because otherwise
it's easy to get completely confused ok
so divergence and gradients are
completely different things the only
thing they have in common is that both
are what's called a first order
differential operator that means it
involves the first partial derivatives
of whatever you put into it but one of
them goes from functions to vector such
gradient everyone goes from vectors to
functions with the variance and curl
later we'll go from vectors to vectors
but that will be later ok
let's see more questions okay so
let's see so how are we going to
actually prove this theorem well if you
remember how we prove greens theorem a
while ago the answer is we're going to
do it exactly the same way now if you
don't remember then I'm going to explain
okay so the first thing we need to do is
actually a simplification so instead of
proving the divergence theorem namely
this equality up there I'm going to
actually prove something easier I'm
going to prove that the flux of a vector
field that has only a Z component is
actually equal to the triple integral of
well the divergence of this is just R
sub Z DV okay now how do I go back to
the general case well I will just prove
the same thing for a vector field that
has only an X component or only a Y
component and then I will add these
things together so if you think
carefully about what happens when you
evaluate this you know you'll have some
formula for NDS and when you do the dot
product you'll end up with a sum P times
something plus Q times something plus R
times something and basically we are
just dealing with the last term R times
something and showing that it's equal to
what it should be and when we face such
terms together we'll get the general
case okay so then we get but in our case
by summing one such identity for each
component
make safe research identities one for
each component what it okay now let's
make a second simplification because I'm
still not feeling confident improve this
right away for any surface I'm going to
do it first for what's called a
vertically simple region
okay so vertically simple means it will
be something on which I can set up an
integral over the Z variable first
easily so it's something that has a
bottom face and a top face and then some
vertical sides
okay so let's say let's look first at
what happens if the given region D is
vertically simple so vertically simple
means it looks like this it has the top
it has the bottom and it has some
vertical sides so if you want you know
if I look at it from above it projects
to some region in the XY plane let's
call that R and it lives between the top
face and the bottom face let's say the
top face is Z equals z2 of XY the bottom
face is Z equals Z 1 of XY and I don't
need to know actual formulas I'm just
going to work with these and prove
things independently of what the
formulas will be for these functions
okay so in your vertically simple region
is something that lives above about of
the XY plane and it is between two
graphs of two functions so let's see
what we can do in that case okay so the
right hand side of this equality so
that's the triple integral let's start
computing it okay so of course we will
we will not be able to get a number out
of it because we don't know actually
formulas for anything but at least we
can start simplifying because the way
this region looks like say this is d
tells me that I can start setting up the
triple integral at least in the other
where I integrate first of all Z okay so
I can actually do it as a triple
integral of our Z DZ DX dy
dy/dx doesn't matter so what are the
bounds on Z see this is actually good
practice to remember how we set up
triple integrals so remember when we
integrate first over Z we start by
fixing a point x and y and for that
value of x and y we look at a small
vertical slice and see from where to
where we have to go well we start at Z
equals whatever the value is at the
bottom z1 of x and y and we go up to the
top face z2 of x and y now for X&Y I'm
not going to actually set up bounds
because I oh sorry I've already called
our the quantity that I'm integrating so
let me change this to say U or something
like that if you already have an hour I
mean there's not much risk for confusion
but still okay so I'm going to call you
the shadow of my region instead so now I
want to integrate over all values of x
and y that are in the shadow of my
region that means it's a double integral
over this region U which I haven't
described to you so I can't actually set
up bounds for X and y but I'm going to
just leave it like this okay now you see
if you look at how you would start
evaluating this well the inner integral
certainly is not scary because you're
integrating the derivative of R with
respect to Z integrating that with
respect to Z so you should get our back
okay so triple integral over D of RZ DV
becomes well we'll have a double
integral over you of so the inner
integral becomes R at the point on the
top so that means remember R is a
function of XY and Z and in fact I will
plug into it the value of Z at the top
so z of XY minus
the value of our at the point on the
bottom X Y Z 1 of X Y ok any questions
about this is it looking vaguely
believable yeah okay so now let's
compute the other side because here we
are stuck we won't be able to do
anything else
so let's look at the flux integral ok we
have to look at the flux of this vector
field for the entire surface s which is
the whole boundary of D so that consists
of a lot of pieces namely the top the
bottom and the sides so the other side
so let me just remind us is bottom plus
top plus side of this vector field that
NDS equals
ok so what do we have so first we have
to look at the bottom now let's start
with the top actually sorry ok so let's
start with the top
so just to remind you well okay let's do
all of them so let's look at the table
first so we need to set up the flux
integral for vector field dot NDS we
need to know what NDS is well
fortunately for us we know that the top
phase is going to be the graph of some
function of x and y so we've seen a
formula for NDS in this kind of
situation we've seen that NDS so just to
remind you this is the graph of a
function Z equals z2 of X Y so we've
seen NDS four that is negative partial
derivative of this function with respect
to X negative partial Z to respect to y
one dxdy
and well we can't compute this guys but
it's not a big deal because if we do the
dot product with zero zero r dot NDS
that will give us well you know if you
dot this with zero zero are these terms
go away you just have our DX dy so that
means that the double integral for flux
for the top of our vector field that NDS
becomes double integral over the top of
our DX dy and now how do we evaluate
that actually well so R is a function of
X Y Z but we said we have only two
variables that we're going to use we're
going to use x and y we're going to get
rid of see how do we get rid of Z well
if we're on the top surface Z is given
by this formula z2 of X Y so I plug Z
equals z2 of XY into the form
left forearm whatever it may be then I
integrate DX dy and what's the range for
X&Y well my surface sets exactly above
this region you in the XY plane so it's
double integral over you any questions
about how I set up this flux integral
okay let me close the door actually okay
so we've got one of the two terms that
we had over there let's try to get the
others so
no comment okay so we need to look also
at the other parts of our surface for
the flux integral so the bottom well it
will work quite much the same way right
because it's the graph of a function Z
equals Z 1 of X Y so we should be able
to get NDS using the same method
negative tough respect to X negative
partial with respect to y one dxdy now
there's a small catch okay we have to
think a bit carefully about orientations
so remember when we set up the
divergence theorem we need the normal
vectors to point out of our region which
means that on the top surface we want n
pointing up but on the bottom face we
want n pointing down
so in fact we shouldn't use this formula
here because that one corresponds to the
other orientation well we could use it
and then subtract but the time is just
going to say that n DX is actually the
opposite of this so I'm going to switch
all my signs okay that's the other side
of the formula when you re-enter your
graph with n pointing downwards now if I
do things the same way as before I will
get that zero zero r dot NDS will be
negative r dxdy
and so when i do the double integral
over the bottom i'm going to get the
double integral over the bottom of
negative r dxdy which if i try to
evaluate that well actually we'll have
to integrate so in first I will have to
substitute the value of Z value of Z
vadai we want to plug into our will be
given by you know z1 of XY
and the bounds of integration will be
given again by the shadow of our surface
which is again this guy you okay so we
seem to be all set except we are still
missing one part of our surface s
because we also need to look at the
sides well what about the sides
well our vector field zero zero R is
actually vertical it's parallel to the z
axis so my vector field does something
like this everywhere and while that
makes it very interesting on the top and
bottom that means that on the sides
really not much is going on right no
matter is passing through the vertical
side so the side the sides are vertical
so 0 0 R is tangent to the side and
therefore the flux for the sides is just
going to be 0 ok no calculation needed
that's because of course that's the
reason why I simplified first things so
that my vector field would only have a Z
component well not just that but that's
the main place where it becomes very
useful so now if I compare my double
integral and my flux in so in my triple
integral and my flux integral I get that
they are indeed the same
well that's the statement of a feeling
we're trying to prove affinity arrays it
okay
okay so just to recap we got a formula
for the triple integral of R sub Z DV
it's a bad right up and we got formulas
for the flux for the top and the bottom
and the sides and when you add them
together you get indeed the same formula
top plus bottom plus side of okay and so
we have actually completed the proof for
this part now well that's only for
vertically simple region so if d is not
vertically simple what do we do when we
cut it into vertically simple pieces
okay so concretely you know say that I
wanted to integrate over a solid
doughnut then that's not vertically
simple because here in the middle I have
you know not only this top on this
bottom but I have like this middle phase
so the way I would cut my donut would be
probably I would slice it no not in the
way that you would usually slice we
donate our bagel but like this problem
are spectacular if you think that
there's a bagel then the mathematicians
way of slicing it is like this into five
pieces okay
and that's not very convenient for
eating but that's convenient for
integrating over it because now each of
these pieces has a well-defined top and
bottom face and of course you've
introduced some vertical sides but we
don't really care what the vertical
sides for two reasons one is that we've
said the flux for M is zero anyway so
who bothers you know who cares sorry why
bother but also you know if you sum the
flux through the surface of each little
piece where you see that you will be
integrating twice over each of these
vertical cuts once when you do this
piece you'll be taking the flux for this
right guy with normal vector pointing to
the right and once when you take this
middle little piece you'll be taking the
flux for that cut surface again but now
with normal vector pointing the other
way around so in fact you'll be summing
the flux for these guys twice with
opposite orientations they cancel out
well and again because of what we were
doing actually the integral was just
zero anyway so we didn't matter but even
if it hadn't simplified that would do it
for us
okay so that's how we do it with a
general region and then as I said at the
beginning when we can do it for a vector
field that has only a Z component well
we can also do it for vector field that
has only an X or only a Y component and
then we sum together and we get the
general case so that's the end of the
proof
so you see the idea is really the same
as for Green's theorem
yes oh there's only four pieces thank
you yes I first knew the seconds of
mathematicians those who know how to
count and those who don't
well
okay
so okay now so I hope that you can see
already the interest of this theorem for
you know the divergence theorem for
computing flux integrals just for the
sake of computing flux integrals like
might happen on the problem set or on
the next test but let me tell you also
why it's important physically to
understand equations that had been
observed empirically well before there
were actually understood in terms of how
things go so let's look at something
called the diffusion equation so let me
explain to you what it does so the
diffusion equation is something that
governs well what's called diffusion
diffusion is when you have a fluid in
which you're introducing some substance
and you won't figure out how that thing
is going to spread out the technical
term is diffuse into the ambient fluid
so for example that governs the motion
of say smoke in the air or you know if
you put dye in a solution or things like
that that will tell you you know say
that you actually drop some ink into a
glass of water well you can imagine that
obviously it will get diluted into there
and that equation will tell you how
exactly over time this thing is going to
spread out and start filling the entire
glass so what's the equation well we
need first to know what we unknown will
be so it's a partial differential
equation okay so the unknown is a
function and the equation will relate
the partial derivatives of that function
to each other so you the unknown will be
the concentration at a given point
and of course that depends on the point
where you are so that depends on X Y Z
the location where you are but since the
goal is to also understand how things
played over time it should also depend
on the time otherwise we are not going
to get very far and in fact what the
equation will give us is the derivative
of U with respect to T it will tell us
how the concentration at a given point
varies over time in terms of how the
concentration varied in space so it will
relate partial u partial T to partial
derivatives with respect to x y&z
[Applause]
so okay so what's the equation the
equation is partial u partial T equals
some constant let me call that constant
K times something I will call del
squared u which is also called the
laplacian of u and what is that well
that means okay so just to scare u del
square is this which means it's the
divergence of gradient you that we've
used this notation for gradient okay so
if you actually expand it in terms of
variables that becomes partial u over
partial x squared plus partial squared u
over partial Y squared plus partial
squared u over partial Z squared okay so
the equation is this equals that okay so
that's a weird-looking equation and I'm
going to have to explain to you where
does it come from okay but before I do
that I mean well let me point out
actually this equation is not just the
diffusion equation it's also known as
the heat equation and that's because
exactly the same equation governs how
temperature changes over time when you
know you have gain so so I should have
been actually more careful I should have
said this is in yeah that's not moving
okay and same thing with a solution and
if you drop some ink into your glass of
water well if you start staring
obviously it will mix much faster than
if you don't do anything okay so that's
the case where we don't actually the
fluid is not
moving and the heat equation now does
the same but for temperature in a fluid
that's at rise that's not moving it
tells you how the heat goes from you
know the warmest parts to the coldest
parts and eventually temperatures should
somehow even out so in the heat equation
that would just be this you would just
measure the temperature for no
temperature of your fluid at a given
point actually doesn't have to be a
fluid it could be a solid forward heat
equation
so you know for example say that you
have a big box made of metal or
something and you know you do some
heating at one side you want to know how
quickly is the other side going to get
hurt well you can use the equation to
figure out you know say that you have a
metal bar and you keep one side that I
don't know 400 degrees because it in
your oven how quickly will the other
side get warm okay so it's the same
equation for both phenomena even further
of course different phenomenon well the
physical reason why they are the same is
actually that phenomena are different
but not all that much involve actually
how the atoms and molecules actually
moving and hitting each other inside
this medium okay so anyway what's the
explanation for this so to understand
the explanation and given what we've
been doing we should have a vector field
in there so I'm going to think of the
flow of well let me say let's imagine
that we're doing motion of smoke in air
so that was the flow of a smoke that
means you know at every point it's a
vector which direction tells me in which
direction the smoke is actually moving
and it's magnitude tells me how fast
it's moving and also what amount of
smoke is moving
so there's two things to understand one
is how the disparities in the
concentration between different points
cause the flow to be there you know how
smoke will flow from the regions where
there's more smoke to the regions where
there's less smoke and that's actually
physics but in a way it's also common
sense so physics and common sense tell
us that the smoke will flow from high
concentration towards low concentration
regions
okay so if we think of this function nu
that measures concentration that means
we are always going to go in the
direction where the concentration
decreases the fastest well what's that
that's negative gradient so f is
directed along minus gradient view now
how big is going to be well there you
have to come up with some intuition for
how the two are related and the easiest
relation you can think of is that we
might be just proportional so you know
the steeper of the differences in
concentration the faster of the flow
will be the motor will be flow and if
you try to think about it as you know
molecules moving in random directions
you will see it makes actually complete
sense but anyway it's kind of it should
be part of your physics class not part
of what I'm telling you so I'm just
going to accept that the flow is just
proportional to the gradient of U so if
you want if the differences between
concentrations at different points are
very small then the flow will be very
gentle and if on the other hand you have
huge disparities when things will try to
even out faster okay so that's the first
part now we need to understand the
second part which is once we know how
the flow is going how does that affect
the concentration you know if smoke is
going that way and it means the
concentration here should be decreasing
and there should be increasing so that's
relation between F and partial u partial
T
and that part is actually math namely
the divergence film so let's try to
understand that part more carefully
so let's take a small piece of you know
a small region in space D bounded by a
surface s okay so I want to figure out
what's going on in here so let's look at
the flux out of the OS well we said that
this flux would be given by double
integral on s of F dot NDS so this flux
measures how much smoke is passing flow
s per unit time let's the amount of
smoke for s per unit time but now how
can I think of that how can i compute
that differently well I can compute it
just by looking at the total amount of
smoke in this region and saying how much
it changes know if I'm gaining or losing
smoke it means it's must be going out
there well unless I have a smoker in
here but that's not part of the data so
that should be sorry that's the same
thing as the derivative with respect to
T of the total amount of smoke in the
region which is given by the triple
integral of U if I integrate the
concentration of smoke which means the
amount of smoke per unit volume over D I
will get the total amount of smoke in D
except well let's see this flux is
counted positively if we go out of these
so actually it's minus the derivative
this is the amount of smoke that we are
losing per unit time so
now we are almost there well let me
actually
because we know yet another way to
compute this guy using the divergence
theorem right so this part here is just
like common sense and thinking about
what it means the divergence theorem
tells me this is also equal to the
triple integral in D of div F DV so what
I got is that the triple integral over D
of div F DV equals this derivative well
let's think a bit about this derivative
so see you're integrating a function of
XY and Z and then you're differentiating
with respect to T I claim that you can
actually switch the order in which you
do things so when we think about it is
you know here you're taking the total
amount of smoke and then seeing how that
changes over time so you're taking the
derivative of the sum of all the small
amounts of smoke very well well that
would be the sum of the derivatives of
the amount of smoke into each little box
inside each little box so we can
actually move the differential sorry the
derivative into the integral so let's
see
I said minus D DT triple integral over D
u DV and then now I'm saying this is the
same as the triple integral in D of D u
DT DV and the reason why this is going
to work is you should think of it as DDT
of a some of you of you know some values
you plug in the values of your points at
that given time time is the small volume
you sum them and when you take the
derivative and now you see the
derivative of this sum is the sum of the
derivatives
why I CIT so if you think about what the
integral measures that's actually pretty
easy and it's because this variable here
is not the same as the variables on
which were integrating that's why we can
do it okay so now if we have this for
any region D so we have a function of X
Y Z T and we have another function here
and whenever we integrate them anywhere
we get the same answer well that must
mean they are the same right just think
of what happens if you just take D to be
a tiny little box you'll get roughly the
value of div F at that point times the
volume of a box or you'll get probably
the value of D u DT at that point times
the volume of a little box so the values
must be the same well let me actually
explain that a tiny bit better so what I
get is that one of our let me let me
divide by the volume of the so I
promised I'm done in a minute
is the same thing as one of the volume D
of negative D u DT DV so that means the
average value okay maybe that's the best
way cleaning it the average of give F in
D is equal to the average of minus
partial u partial T in D and that's true
for any region D not just for some
regions but for really any region I can
think of so the outcome is that actually
the divergence of F is equal to minus D
u DT and that's another way to think
about what divergence means the
divergence we said is how much stuff is
actually expanding flowing out that's
how much we are losing
and so now if you combine this with fat
you'll get that D you DT is minus
divergence F which is plus K del square
u okay so you combine this guy with that
guy and you get the diffusion equation